[Music]
new bombshell findings from the
inspector General's office revealing the
National Institute of Health failed to
keep tabs on taxpayer-funded virus
research projects including those at the
Wuhan lab the inspector General's office
saying quote based on the findings we
conclude that NIH missed opportunities
to more effectively monitor research
with improved oversight NIH may have
been able to take more timely corrective
actions to mitigate the inherent risks
associated with that type of research
Iowa Congressman marionette Miller Meeks
joins me now Congressman thanks so much
for being here why I'm trying to get at
the Y what else better does the NIH and
the bureaucrats there have to do
then uncover every single Stone to make
sure they are protecting the health of
every single American this makes no
sense
precisely and that's exactly what the
select subcommittee on the coronavirus
pandemic is going to do so I'm pleased
that uh we're having this select
subcommittee our focus is going to be
very different to look at the origins of
covid-19 and there's valid reasons to do
that this is not a partisan Endeavor but
there are valid reasons as you mentioned
biosafety security where NIH funding
goes whether it's grants or it's
sub-grants how do we prevent the next
pandemic and have timely disclosure uh
so that we could you know Nations can
prepare so there are valid reasons to do
this and I'm delighted that we're going
to be getting this under way under the
leadership of Dr Brad winstrup yeah your
colleagues in the Senate proposing a new
bill as well to install a watchdog
within the NIH Senator Marsha Blackburn
saying quote as the nation's leading
medical research agency the NIH oversees
thousands of researchers and institutes
however they have been far from
transparent the American people deserve
to know that their tax dollars are being
spent responsibly and to advance
scientific research yeah so if you're
funding research with these taxpayer
dollars how do you not make sure that
that money is not going to create a
deadly pathogen that makes no sense as
well
yeah exactly we can't prove that the
money that went to Eco health so there
was eight million dollars over a period
from 2014 to 2021. we can't prove that
that led to or at this time can't prove
it led to SARS cov2 but nonetheless
there was oversight that was lacking
there was not oversight of Eco health
and then where they granted money to Eco
help didn't do any oversight for the
Wuhan Institute of virology and on-site
visit when especially when you know that
there are lab safety violations so we
know that at the Wuhan Institute of
virology they were doing biosafety lab
for research at a biosafety lab 2 area
so there needs to be research in into
that there needs to be oversight and
we're certainly going to hold these
agencies accountable broader question
congresswoman why are we still funding
our main adversary in this world China
well that brings up a very larger
question we've already passed a bill to
prevent research uh from uh you know or
excuse me to prevent oil from being
released from the Strategic petroleum
Reserve to be sold to China and I think
these are another this is another area
that we can look at but the
International Community has you know a
vested interest in finding out where the
origins of covid-19 came from for
exactly that reason is there gain of
function or unethical research being
conducted and what's the international
community's response is are there lab
breaks is the appropriate kind of
research being done at the appropriate
biosafety lab so you're not having a
biosafety lab for research conducted in
an inappropriate facility which can lead
to a leak in a virus and another
pandemic so these things are very
important that the International
Community has an understanding on and
then disclosure there needs to be
immediate disclosure and as we know
probably in the fall of 2019 they knew
that they had a virus that had linked
but yet that was not disclosed and they
denied human to human transmission
transparency disclosure we got to figure
out what went wrong so that we don't
make the same mistakes again the next
time a pandemic hits Congressman
marionette
exactly appreciate your time as always
thank you so much I'm Steve Ducey I'm
Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart
and click here to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis